dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here
reinforcement learning is a learning
algorithm that we can use to choose a
set of actions in an environment to
maximize a score there are many
applications of such learners but we
typically cite video games because of
the diverse set of challenges they can
present the player with and in
reinforcement learning we typically have
one task like learning backflips and one
agent that we wish to train to perform
it well this work is deep Minds attempt
to supercharge reinforcement learning by
training one agent that can do a much
wider variety of tasks now this clearly
means that we have to acquire more
training data and also be prepared to
process all this data as effectively as
possible by the way the test suite that
you see here is also new where typical
tasks in this environment involve path
finding through mazes collecting objects
finding keys to open their matching
doors and more and every fellow scholar
knows that the paper describing its
details is of course available in the
video description this new technique
builds upon an earlier architecture that
was also published by deep mind this
earlier architecture III C unleashes a
bunch of actors into the wilderness each
of which gets the copy of the play book
that contains the current strategy these
actors then play the game independently
and periodically stop and share what
worked and what didn't - this play book
with this new Impala architecture there
are two key changes to this one in the
middle we have a learner and the actors
don't share what worked and what didn't
- this learner but they share their
experiences instead and later the
centralized learner will come up with
the proper conclusions with all this
data imagine if each football player in
a team tries to tell the coach the
things they tried on the field and what
worked that is surely going to work at
least okay but instead of these
conclusions we could aggregate all the
experience of the players into some sort
of centralized hive mind and get access
to a lot more and higher quality
information maybe we will see that a
strategy only works well if executed by
the players who are known to be faster
than their opponents on the field the
other key difference
is that with traditional reinforcement
learning we play for a given number of
steps then stop and perform learning
with this technique we have decoupled
the playing and learning therefore it is
possible to create an algorithm that
performs both of them continuously this
also raises new questions make sure to
have a look at the paper specifically
the part with the new off policy
correction method by the name V trace
when tested on 30 of these different
levels and a bunch of Atari games the
new technique was typically able to
double the score of the previous III C
architecture which was also really good
and at the same time this is at least 10
times more data efficient and its
knowledge generalizes better to other
tasks we have had many episodes on
neural network based techniques but as
you can see research on the
reinforcement learning side is also
progressing at a remarkable pace if you
have enjoyed this episode and you feel
that eight science videos a month is
worth a dollar please consider
supporting us on patreon you can also
pick up cool perks like early access to
these episodes the link is available in
the video description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time